Let's now consider the
generalization of the result
that the torque on a single
particle about a point
causes the angular momentum of
that particle about that point
to change to a
collection of particles.
So let's begin by indicating
some ith particle with momentum
Pi and some jth particle
over here with momentum Pj.
And this is a big
system of n particles.
And we'd like to
calculate the angular
momentum about some point, s.
So that angular momentum will
consist of the direct product
of the vector from s
to the ith particle
and the direct product of the
vector r s to the jth particle.
So the angular
momentum, total, will
be the sum over all
the particles, 1 to n,
of this sum, rsj cross Pj.
Now, what we'd like to
do is, again, as before,
take the time derivative
of this angular momentum.
We have the sum--
j goes from 1 to n.
We have two derivatives
here, by the product rule,
cross Pj, plus the sum, j
goes from 1 to n of rsj,
cross Fj, where we use the
fact, as we did before,
that the force on
the jth particle
is equal to the change in
momentum of the jth particle.
Now, this first piece,
again, the derivative
of the vector from s to the
jth part is the velocity.
So we have j equals
1 to n of v--
the velocity of
the jth particle--
cross Mj, Pj.
And that's 0, as we know
that a vector cross product
with itself is 0.
And this piece in here--
now, we have to be a
little bit careful--
but rsj cross Fj is the
torque on the jth particle.
So that is the torque
on the jth particle.
Now, remember that we showed
that internal-- the forces
on the jth particle
could be both due
to internal or external forces.
And as long as the
internal forces
pointed between two particles--
pointed along the line
connecting those particles,
the internal torques
cancel in pairs.
And this will only be
the external torque.
So we've assumed that
the internal torques
cancel in pair.
And that has to do with an
assumption about the direction
of the internal forces.
And so we can conclude
that this is just
the total external torque
about the point s, s total.
And we'll drop that
total, and we'll
conclude that the torque
for our system of particles
is just-- causes the angular
momentum of the system
of particles to change.
The calculation is exactly
like the single particle,
with a few subtleties that have
to do with internal torques
canceling in pairs.